so i'm going to be
talking about my story which i'm calling
what does a coder do
if they can't type but i'm also going to
be presenting a manifesto which i'm
calling
accessible means hackable right
so i'm going to talk about my story yes
and part of my story
is about how i dictate my code and how
disabled people take ownership
over their adaptive technology uh
and then we have to talk though about
why it's so hard to find
uh adaptive technology that's hackable
in the way that we need
and then i'm going to talk about you and
what you can do to enable disabled
people to serve their
individual needs but also because
those of you who are able bodied are
only able bodied for now
i'm sorry to break it to you we are
going to spend a little time talking
about the care of your hacker hands
how you can take care of your body and
how you should respond
once taking care isn't enough so
first i want to talk about who i
was i'd been programming since the age
of 12 and i was a phd student
studying computer science and machine
learning natural language processing
in my spare time i also enjoyed
programming in a variety of languages
i had other hobbies as well martial arts
bicycling knitting
needle felting so i
i had a lot going on in my life
now i'm going to talk about who i am
uh so first off
uh i uh in 2015
there we go in 2015 pain i was ignoring
in my hands built to a level where i
couldn't ignore it and not only that but
i couldn't even uncurl my fingers
so doctors were completely baffled and
for about a month i couldn't do anything
but drink vodka with a straw and i like
to tell that like it's a joke a lot of
the time but the fact is that i've been
in pain now for five years
so who am i i couldn't do the same craft
hobbies that i did so i got into comedy
service work social media overuse and
reading obsessively i couldn't do
martial arts or biking
but i needed a contact sport in my life
which is how i started roller derby
this is me knocking someone over my
roller derby name is gaussian
retribution
yeah but uh what could i do about
programming
i couldn't type i couldn't
write and that's how i got into voice
coding
just by dictating all my code with talon
i managed to resume my phd
i've written code and papers on
understanding the training
dynamics of language models
learning trying to understand why
they're biased towards linguistic
structure and i really enjoy my work
when just a few years ago i couldn't
imagine any path forward that didn't
involve some kind of miracle cure
when you have a disability every path
forward requires that you ensure
that technology serves your needs and
not the needs
imagined by someone else so that means
that your tools have to be hackable and
i'm going to use my case as an example
so talon it's a scriptable interface for
dictating code and the thing that sets
it apart from a standard speech
text system um like the default one for
dragon
or the built-in system on many computers
is that it offers a powerful api so
programmers can customize it with their
own macros and scripts
so you can set specific commands that
only work with a particular app
or even with a particular file extension
so that means you have separate keywords
for working with a python file or a
c file and there's a dedicated community
who create
individual libraries of commands so
there are people who make them for
pearl or make them for julia or for
some random app a lot of the basic
functionality
gets added so keywords represent
combinations of symbols uh common
commands like
command shift s but also like
combination of symbols where you go open
parentheses
versus a function call that's two
parentheses
versus a uh a
command that says oh open parentheses
and also i want to dictate in between
the parentheses
press a left arrow uh it has its own
phonetic alphabet
so if i wanted to say my own name i
would say sky near
air odd made sit um
sky means upper case so
the ability to have macros though is
also really
important and when it comes to it's
difficult to dictate commands and
strings
for instance i have a command set up
that just
repeats the previous command so a common
use case of this
is i'm doing something like substituting
a particular word with another word and
i don't want to do a global substitution
um because i want to check each
individual word so
maybe the substitution command is
annoying to dictate so i would just say
creek
over and over again to repeat the
previous command
another command that i have set up is an
indexed clipboard
because it's so important to not have to
repeat yourself a lot
it's useful to be able to have multiple
ad hoc
commands to represent strings so you
might use this to copy every variable
name that you've dictated
individually so you can later refer back
to them with easily pronounceable
keywords
rather than having to repeat your like
alphabet soup of
abbreviations and underscores so
after selecting a particular phrase
using my cursor control commands
i say clip keyword and every time i want
to enter the same phrase
after i say paste keyword and therefore
only have to dictate a particularly
obnoxious
variable name once however it does
introduce
the new challenge where every variable
has two names
its written name and its spoken name
which exacerbates the
difficulty of naming variables the
hardest problem in
computer science and by the way
when i do sarcastic quotes i can only do
this
that's one effect of my disability okay
um this is actually one of a number of
commands
that um are just re-implementations i
reimplemented that one
from a previously popular co voice
coding system which was called voice
code
because a lot of the talon community
came from
the voice code community it was useful
for us to re-implement a lot of commands
lots of people even replaced the
phonetic alphabet that was used in talon
with a phonetic alphabet that was the
voice code default so they didn't have
to learn a new phonetic alphabet
in a way that kind of thing is probably
recognizable to people who are
power users of emacs or vim
where every user has their own config
file and in order to get the most out of
a system
uh like that you really do have to know
the scripting or the command language
behind it um if you're looking to get
into voice coding the best way is to
just look through all the different
scripts on the
talon community repository that way you
can see
the tools others find useful there's no
single standard set of commands or
workflow so it's just about what you
find useful and some people even use
like eye tracking systems to replace
their mouse
uh now everyone probably wants a quick
demo
the way i would say this is shrink
integer
skoosh word main call scooch
kirkshock word print prex coif
phrase hello world ricky semi
so yeah in order to learn these commands
um i added script gradually from the
community repository
um joined the slack pasted the command
list on my wall
at home in front of my desk and also
because that's not
like the only place that i work i also
covered the whole wall
around my bed with uh the
printed out commands so
and i and i would also pick a command of
the day
each day uh and try to use it
but it's not hard to find communities
like talons which are full of disabled
people who are fulfilling their own
needs and building their own tools and
modifying those tools so another
good example is uh blind programmers
and a while ago i talked to a blind
programmer who's in my field about his
setup and he had this elaborate
configuration
built with emac speak so his browser
his messaging any work he did was just a
screen reader interfacing with emacs
plugins
and this actually isn't an unusual setup
for a blind programmer who uses linux
now i had a good friend from undergrad
who also happened to be blind
and his screenwriter who screener was so
elaborate it had syntax highlighting and
everything
and one day i asked him oh you use emac
speak right and he
just laughed and said i don't use emacs
as my
operating system and it turned out he
used orca which is the screen reader
that comes with no
i just want you to think about this not
only are there multiple options
with elaborate configuration options
that were developed by blind people for
their own needs
but there are so many platform options
that someone can make a selection based
on what is
frankly aesthetic criteria
they didn't want emacs as their
operating system right
um so that's the strength of the blind
programmer community it's basically a
paradise as far as i can tell it's
this ideal world where everyone's able
to make their own modifications that are
appropriate
for their own work even though there's a
huge
number of programmers with rsi
repetitive stress injuries the number of
programmers
for people who don't want to use their
the number of platforms for
people who don't want to use their uh
hands is pretty limited and they
often struggle to integrate them with
proprietary
speech recognition systems so
um let's talk about why we don't
have this paradise
i think there are three factors for why
disabled people's
tools are not hackable
there's the drive for profit there's
contempt for
accessibility and adaptive technology as
a field
and there's patronizing attitudes
towards disabled people
first we're going to talk about profit
so like many people who dictate to a
computer
for years i depended on dragon dragon is
a proprietary piece of software
developed by nuance
which was available for windows and osx
they weren't really good speech
recognition
alternatives at the time which is why
everyone depended on it
and then in 2018 nuance discontinued
support for
and seals of dragon on osx which is what
i depended on at the time
and it just wasn't profitable which
meant that an essential service for many
disabled people just
like no longer existed uh and because it
was proprietary the software was no
longer available
it's because of this that ryan heilman
the programmer behind
talon has actually been developing free
alternative models that are easier to
integrate with which is really nice
but we can talk about another example
from the diabetic
hacker community diabetics don't have a
functioning pancreas so that's the organ
that monitors your blood sugar level
and changes your insulin levels so that
it doesn't get too high
and it doesn't set too low so a typical
diabetic medical equipment has uh for a
long time
included a blood testing meter to check
your glucose levels
and an insulin pump or if you're less
lucky a
needle to adjust those levels
typically a diabetic repeats the same
procedure throughout the day
they check their blood they adjust their
insulin level manually according to some
heuristics about that glucose level
and they wait until it's been a while or
they notice symptoms of how
low or high blood sugar and rinse repeat
the holy grail if you're a diabetic
would be an
artificial pancreas a system that
monitors your blood sugar and has its
own internal heuristics that are
personalized to your body to inject
insulin
or at least when you measure your blood
sugar it would automatically respond
appropriately with those heuristics
um that was the idea behind the closed
loop
a system developed by diabetics and
their carers
they used diet the data from glucose
monitors to
build personal heuristics and uh they
got it and they used standard uh
medical pumps from medtronics just uh
they were
easily adapted because um the
authentication
code was the six-digit serial number
of the device in plain text and it was
publicly known
since 2011 but medtronic just
didn't really care until it started
cutting into
their profits and then suddenly this
vulnerability was grounds for a recall
of the pumps um that could be used for a
closed loop
even though these diy systems like uh
omnipod uh relied on the same
pairing protocol as the standard
controls
so device manufacturers have portrayed
it as an exploit
that creates a security risk
even though it's just using the same
controls as the standard controls
so uh device manufacturers
would sometimes claim oh this is a
regulatory issue
they claimed they couldn't document
their own apis because it would be
promoting
off-label use which was prohibited but
now america's food and drug
administration
has added designations for pumps that
allow third-party access
the icgm which is an interoperable
glucose monitor
and the ace pump which is a alternate
controller enabled
pump and yet these device and
manufacturers have completely failed
to enable diabetics to freely treat
themselves
uh even though they have the ability to
in america at least
uh one monitor manufacturer abbott labs
even went after a free tool for
accessing your own medical data
because they claimed a copyright
violation against them
diabetes
so this isn't about security and it's
not about regulation it's about
protecting their own profits because
they have
failed to offer products that are as
good
as what diabetic hackers create for
themselves
the next thing i want to talk about is
the contempt
that developers and engineers have for
accessibility work
a lot of people see this as less
interesting than more prestigious areas
so a lot of the essential work actually
gets left to women which is
very noticeable in tech fields where
there often aren't many women
in fact a lot of the essential work of
building
platforms and products within companies
is uh left to disabled people themselves
as though the only reason you could
possibly care about this is if you
are going to have to use it obviously
hopefully uh you may have gotten from
the rest of my talk that i'm entirely in
favor of disabled people being
enabled to fulfill their own needs every
individual has different needs
we should be able to build the tools for
our work and
lives but we shouldn't always have to
and yet this is an expectation of us
my aforementioned blind friend who is an
extremely skilled systems programmer
was assigned to an accessibility team
for years
doing work that wasn't actually what he
was excited about
and i work in language model research
language model plays a part in many
kinds of systems machine translation
conversation question answering and yet
anyone i meet immediately assumes if
they know about my disability
that i work in speech recognition uh
but like i don't work on anything that
has an application for me personally
i don't work on anything that is in any
kind of
application area i do interpretability
research which is
pretty far from anything in the applied
world
so one problem that emerges though
because of all of this sort of contempt
for the field
is a lack of qualified and skilled
programmers working in accessibility
and that means that products are often
badly engineered
insulin pumps often have vulnerabilities
that you could literally
use to kill a person because if you dump
a lot of insulin into someone's body
they die and they often never get fixed
essential updates are released really
slowly if at
all the the dexcom glucose
monitor provides updates to the apple
health
app but delays them by three hours for
instance and
initially this was to conform with fda
designation but they now have the
interoperability designation which i
mentioned
and that means they could be updating on
time
but they don't have the upgrade
to update in real time and the only real
explanation
at this point is that they can't recruit
enthusiastic qualified people
who are proactive in upgrading that app
building a team like that is always
going to be hindered by the contempt
that skills developers have towards
accessibility work and adaptive
technology
now i want to talk about patronizing
attitudes
that uh we have towards disabled people
our society does not trust disabled
people to take care of their own needs
or be authorities on their own
conditions and
this is a problem that starts on the
most direct level with
doctors and so i'm going to rant to you
about doctors
my first diagnosis was fibromyalgia
which is a way of dismissing a patient
that you don't have a diagnosis
for so doctors will rarely try to
actually find out the cause
if they've already declared you have
fibromyalgia
which is just like fibromyalgia it's a
way of repeating your symptoms back at
you
but then the mechanism of my pain was
discovered
which is small fiber neuropathy which
means i'm missing nerves that
transmit heat and pain which causes a
kind of phantom limb syndrome kind of
thing in my feet and hands
i got this diagnosis in america through
a skin biopsy which is a standard
procedure for diagnosing
throughout america england pretty much
the whole world but not in scotland
where i now live
so when i saw a neurologist in scotland
solely for the purpose
of having my diagnosis in my scottish
medical records
the neurologist wasn't familiar with the
test
and i needed him to sign off on this
because
i needed painkillers
scotland doesn't actually have a test
for small fiber neuropathy though
instead the neurologist wrote down that
he suspected
significant functional overlay keep in
mind this is how i do
scare quotes uh this is the way
that a doctor directly says that pain is
just
all in your head so that means when i
next
saw my gp he refused to send me to any
more doctors or prescribe me painkillers
and instead offered to send me to a
psychologist who would help me to
resolve the underlying issues that i had
with my mother that were the underlying
true cause of my pain and i was then
ejected from
his office for saying the word [ __ ]
um eventually i found an actual
neuropathy specialist
in glasgow so i now have my actual
diagnosis on the record in
scotland
so we don't have a culture that respects
disabled people or trusts them to know
their own needs
the diabetic hacker community passes
around nightmare stories about doctors
that won't treat them because they
aren't using the standard systems
but they have these really great shirts
that say deliberately non-compliant
yeah but now
i'm going to talk to you as an ally for
disabled people
first off consider working in
accessibility tech we need data
scientists
to develop better cybernetic medical
technology
we need better data engineers to ensure
that we have access to our own data
possibly in real time and we need better
developers in general who
are aware of what's required of them to
make a product accessible but secure
if you're an employer you need to
understand that you have to
give disabled programmers space this is
especially true if they're in the early
stages of learning to adapt to their
disability
they're gonna take time to learn to use
new tools
and the kind of work they do might
evolve
i spent a lot more time reading papers
as an element of my research than i used
to do when all i wanted to do was hack
but for me my biggest allies have been
people who find me
private offices i can't dictate in an
open office
environment without me wanting to kill
everyone around me
who's making noise and them wanting to
kill me for just talking continually at
a computer for hours and hours on end so
if you want to
accommodate voice coding you've got to
ditch open office environments
they're productivity killers anyway it's
known
a lot of people are just not going to
play well with them anyway
uh why is this really relevant to you
though
um i want to talk to you as a crumbling
sack of bones and flesh that will
inevitably decay
because you are an athlete
you are an athlete who sits on your ass
all day using your fingers which are
like the bits of your bodies that are
least well adapted to constant use
normal athletes like if you worked for
football or something
have physical therapists and masseuses
and that's just
part of their job but it's likely that
you don't have that as part of your job
and it should change honestly but i want
to give a few quick
tips for if you find that your hands
have been failing you
i'm going to explain this to you because
i
learned a lot actually about
hands through my journey
since it took me over a year to get a
diagnosis that's like
i don't have a repetitive stress injury
so yeah i can tell you all about how
the little arms on the end of your big
arms
ah they are um very delicate
so there are three big nerves going down
your arm
there's the radial nerve that travels up
the back of your hand
and if you pain feel pain there it might
indicate that you're
crunching your wrist when you type with
your palm facing too much
upward rather than parallel to the
forearm i hope everyone can actually see
that
the ulnar nerve then travels up the
pinky
and i would say the most common injury
to it in programmers is
emax pinky where you're constantly
cording your hand
to reach the escape key the most common
injuries however are
uh the median nerve
which travels along the thumb and
pointer finger and that's the one you've
always got to watch out for
often though the tension or inflammation
that you're dealing with
isn't anywhere close to the hands keep
in mind your nerves might be pinched
further up
because those nerves do come out of the
neck
and a lot of programmers have really bad
posture
i'm not going to give you a big lecture
about ergonomics because there's a lot
of information
available about that but it might be
working
worth uh looking into as an athlete
so the most important preventative
measure is going to be taking breaks
if you do some kind of pomodoro time
where you set a
timer for 25 minutes and then take a
five minute break
you're already doing really great that's
the ideal setup
in terms of taking breaks
uh this is a weird piece of advice that
i have found it really helpful
personally um it's uh
when you sit down at a table don't lift
your hands from below
instead bring them around and feel how
much it opens your shoulder just
like try it right now because nobody's
gonna
see you looking silly because you're all
just at home
so like just feel how it changed your
posture
um the next piece of advice i have for
you
is that you should be taking breaks
uh if you want to prevent
record uh like the chording that i
mentioned
that the emacs pinky thing uh you should
actually be using both
shift keys a lot of people will rely
on say the left side which means that
they press a key on the left side
when they're stretching and they they
stretch their hand
to like reach both
shift and that key so if you try using
the
right key when you can press the left
handed letter
um then that can really help
with pain uh even if it's kind of hard
to build up that habit
my next piece of advice is that you
should be taking breaks
uh whoop exercise has been
legitimately shown to help with
inflammatory conditions so
if you want to prevent inflammation and
tension or you want to resolve
inflammation that's been building up
then
you should try exercising more and
my next piece of advice is that you
should take breaks
i love this one
you can stretch or exercise during your
breaks and that's actually
really good for you so uh the
only real radial nerve stretch i know is
just
stretching literally like the back of
the hand
um and here i'm doing it on the camera i
hope people can see me
then the ulnar nerve stretch i know is a
lot more fun
if you can uh if you can do it
right now it's like just try to
do the weird glasses hands
and if you feel it along the
side of your arm under the pinky then
that's
doing a good ulnar stretch and then
the um yes
the median nerve stretch that you should
try is that you tilt your
head to one shoulder you take the
opposite arm from that shoulder and you
just stretch it out
and unfurl the fingers and you should
probably feel that stretch because it's
because probably your median or just
gets uh
need some lovin
so
um don't overdo that by the way don't
like stretch
all the time because that's also not
good for you
anyway what if it's too late and
you're already feeling a lot of pain
building up you can't type much anymore
um first off stop typing stop using your
phone
just take a break try using comfortable
hand braces i like ones that are
specifically labeled as night braces
because they're just
enormous pillows that go on your hands i
actually
use them for a different purpose which
is that when i go to conferences
i have these huge pillows on my hands so
when people try to
shake my hand they just shake the pillow
so it doesn't hurt my hand
normally handshakes are excruciating uh
yeah so just try that
and um and uh it's
completely legitimate to try taking an
anti-inflammatory if you're having
pain from inflammation um
especially because there's this
inflammatory cycle it's not very well
understood
medically but uh but
you might want to ice your wrists and in
order to also prevent inflammation but
if you're doing stuff that prevents
inflammation do not touch your keyboard
again until you are feeling 100 percent
better because what you're doing is
uh preventing the healing process that
should be responding
to you doing the damage of using your
keyboard
so responding to inflammation
pain with anti-inflammatory strategies
is fine
but don't keep hurting your hands
while you're doing it uh
you might want to get some ergonomic
keyboards
uh or a mouse
uh and you might want to try doing
trigger point massage
on yourself because if you've got some
knot or something
further towards the neck that could be
the cause of pain
so if that didn't work you should
probably see a
physical therapist or a doctor but
a doctor might not be enough and it
might be time to start dictating code or
doing
some other kind of adaptation that
allows you to continue your work as well
as
whatever else you enjoy
so
when you're in this much pain
it is tempting though to think of
yourself as in a waiting room
that the pain is something you just have
to wait out
until a doctor fixes you and you can
resume your life
um i don't care if you find that miracle
cure
there's no resuming your life because
this is your life
this whole bit that you're living in uh
so do not let
a year go by just trapped in the
metaphorical waiting room
it took me a long time to realize that
it was time for me
to do things that made my life enjoyable
in the moment
like learning to dictate code uh rather
than waiting for someone to fix
me uh but
i needed that uh and i needed to
change how i was living my life in order
to reflect
what i could do
so i want to talk about one of my
favorite books it's this
extremely skinny memoir just read it it
takes like an hour or two
uh it's called the sound of a wild snail
eating in it
the author is completely bed bound and
unable to
even just turn her head she doesn't have
the energy to read or follow a film or
listen to music
so one day a friend brings her a bouquet
of flowers and it has a snail on it
and she just watches the snail
and she watches that smell for like
almost a year learning
its habits developing this kinship with
the slow
like neglected little creature and she
as she recovers uh she learns about the
biology of snails
from like academic books and the way
that she talks about snails it's like
it's like the way she talks about a
snail in prose
is it's got more like affection and
attention
than i've read in a lot of love poetry
and
this author thought in the moment that
she was in this waiting room waiting to
recover
but she was just living this profoundly
different life from what she was used to
and that's what you need to do
inspiration words
stop waiting if you are
feeling like you've been in pain for a
long time
so uh here i want to read one quote from
it
as the snail's world grew more familiar
my own human world became less so
my species was so large so rushed and so
confusing i found myself preoccupied
with the energy level of my
visitors and i started to observe them
in the same detail with which i observed
the snail
the random way my friend moved around
the
room astonished me it was as if they
didn't know what to do with their own
energy
they were so careless about it they were
spontaneous
there were spontaneous gestures of their
arms the toss
of a head a sudden bend into a full body
stretch as if it were nothing at all
or they might comb their fingers
unnecessarily through their hair
and the way that you experience the
world
does change like this when you become
disabled
because you have to put so much thought
into your body's new needs
because a lot of things that you used to
take for granted become
untenable and um
and like you really do have to
start thinking about how to adapt the
tools around you
so that they still can serve you
so one more thing uh if you hear about
someone overcoming
what i've overcome and adapting
to what i've adapted to it's very easy
to have
one of two responses it's i could never
do that or
it can't be that hard and you have to
let go of both of those
because it is that hard and you can do
it
okay i am
done with my talking section
or with that part of my talking i have
there's a q a cool thank you very much
naomi
um we do have a couple of questions from
the q a and everyone who's watching
right now can still submit their
questions
one of the first questions we got was
from carson
who is asking that if if you're someone
who wants to work in accessibility tech
do you have any tips on where to get
started
or also maybe related are you aware of
any open source projects that might be
interesting to contribute to to
help accessibility attack oh that's a
good question
um since
since i don't work in accessibility tech
i might not be able to answer it super
well
uh but uh
there are definitely open source
projects i've mentioned
a few of them uh i think that the
diabetic
uh the diabetic response thing
could actually use improved models
honestly if you
are a person who works in time series
stuff
uh and um
like yeah i'm trying to think of
specific open source projects
that have uh that i've run into
i'll i'll put a bookmark in that but
also uh
most companies do have an accessibility
team actually
so there's um like adapt
adaptive technology which is it's whole
a whole other thing
it's um maybe you wanted to
work on like a uh
the the actual tools like heart the the
hardware that's developed
or you know dictation software uh that
kind of thing
but accessibility is actually a team on
a
in a lot of big companies uh so
one thing i would recommend is to just
start thinking about how
tools that you're already working with
might be made more accessible
and uh who they are for and
uh how you might come up with a way to
make them more
freely available for everyone um
yeah so i think that's where i'm
at in terms of uh that question yeah
thank you very much
we also have some other questions um
andrew
asks if you have looked at open humans
i'm not familiar myself with open humans
but he says they're a foundation that
provides a platform from
for aggregating data for patient-driven
research
have you heard of that i actually
haven't
uh i have run into um
there's the the one that i've run into
is actually one where you like
post all of your information and then
it's like there's a bounty
for doctors to look at it and i wonder
uh and i wonder how the stuff that's
posted on
uh okay it's it's it's another one that
i have to put a bookmark in
anyway but how the patients who post on
uh looking for a bounty like looking for
a doctor who can tell them what's wrong
uh how they differ from people who are
just gonna post their data
and uh and hope that in
aggregate it's meaningful uh
yeah there's a lot of this i think is uh
is stuff that that
is ultimately very uh
very individualized and uh
and a lot of the edge cases are people
who are
who have really really rare issues
um when it comes to cluster headaches
actually i don't want to be like that
person
but uh but i'm really interested
in um i'm really interested in the
the effect of like uh electric
uh stimulation not just like i know
someone
who got ect because their cluster
headaches were so bad that they were
really really depressed for years and
years and years and the ect
cured the headache so i'm always really
interested in that
so i don't know if open humans has that
data anyway
yeah well thank you then lastly before
we move on to the next speaker
we have two questions from derek he asks
if it is possible to you to code with
talon instead of
inside of ps code and also if there are
some
similarity between talent voice commands
and vim commands if it helps you to
learn talon if you're already familiar
with finn
uh there's a so so there's a
someone has a really solid library for
vim
that's a that's an easy question i can
answer uh
someone has a really solid library for
coding in vim
um where a lot of the
common things that you would do are just
their own
uh are their own commands but also
because it's
a phonetic alphabet uh it's easy to map
your phonetic alphabet onto a lot of the
vim commands um and as for
vs code i think i've seen that as a
library in the community repository but
i actually use atom so i
it hasn't drawn my eye specifically yeah
oh i see nelson has another question
about whether vocal strain
has become an issue with dictating code
and how i deal with that
the answer is yes um
you can't really code for the same
amount of time
if you're exclusively coding by voice
but there's a
more kind of intense answer to that
which actually goes back to the doctor
thing
doctors are terrible i'm sorry um
so i got tonsillitis in september and it
turned out to be antibiotic resistant
uh which i knew because i took
antibiotics and then it
um went away for like all of two weeks
and then it came back immediately
and i couldn't speak for any of that and
i couldn't write for any of that and i
couldn't type for any of that
which is a really frustrating existence
um but uh the tonsillitis came back and
when the tonsillitis came back i would
go to my doctor
every single week going
because uh because of my neurological
issues it
i it's like it it was a very intense
aggravation
of a nerve um and
my doctor every single week would give
me a lecture about how you can't overuse
antibiotics on things that are clearly
just
viruses and then finally was like this
is just your condition
you're just gonna be like this forever
you can't talk that's just how it is
uh and you can't right you can't type
now you can't talk
that's the way that neurological issues
go and
then i went to a dentist and the dentist
was like oh this is tonsillitis which is
something you can tell if you look in my
mouth
anyway so a couple more
recurrences of that tonsillitis and i
had to get a tonsillectomy and after the
tonsillectomy i had
complications involving the same nerve
because that nerve had just been
aggravated
by months by like over a month of
untreated tonsillitis and then months of
like
repeatedly having to suppress it with
antibiotics
um and that was that made it impossible
to code
it was so frustrating uh and
so i guess the answer there is
you can sustain damage in a lot of ways
to your throat uh including just having
a cold
or something like that and that means
that you cannot code like i live in
total fear of getting just a normal cold
because i know that
for a week i'm not going to be able to
cold code
cold code yeah so all of these things
can cause uh stress to the throat and
it's and
dictating for too long is one of those
i would actually recommend if you
dictate for
long periods of time that you see a
vocal coach
because they have practice in telling
people
how they can effectively reduce strain
while dictating for long periods of time
and other than that you just have to
stay really well hydrated
okay okay it's important yeah well thank
you very much
i want to thank you very much for
agreeing to be your keynote i think your
story was very inspiring and i think
it's always good to be really aware of
accessibility issues and i think
we've all learned something in the past
45 minutes